earlier this year I had the wonderful
privilege of taking part in a TV show
called lost for words now like
everything that I do outside of school
it has to do with learning but before I
show you a little clip of the show
there's something you need to know about
the premise of the show obviously what I
mainly spend my time doing is focusing
on learning in high schools because
that's my background but this show is
all about following The Learning Journey
of adults who really have struggled with
literacy and numeracy throughout their
entire lives I think it's so important
to recognize that not everyone has a
great experience of school in fact a lot
of people for one reason or another
perhaps health or family situations they
didn't get to go to school at all or
they had to leave it early for a variety
of different reasons now that makes it
really challenging when we're going out
into the world and trying to navigate
and understand the things around us when
it's filled with words and letters and
numbers and symbols and so I just was so
amazed by the people who I got to meet
as part of this show they're incredibly
Brave sharing their Journey with us and
their struggles it's actually quite
confronting at different points so as
you watch I hope you are you know
impressed and astonished by the courage
and the progress that these people made
as they got to be part of this show with
me and what I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you first uh just a little bit
of a trailer for the show to give you a
broader sense of what it's all about and
then I will show you a little portion of
the show that I got to be a part of if
you live in Australia I absolutely
encourage you to go to SBS on demand and
watch the entire show there's several
episodes that follow those people
through their entire journey and the
transformation and the progress they
make it's genuinely amazing so I hope
you enjoy this little clip
foreign
words and numbers
surround us
they tell us what to do
where to go they even keep us safe
[Music]
but what if you can't read write
or comprehend them
I thought everything you can jump on
board sorry
[Music]
my name is John I am no good at this
SARS
you have trouble riding
it is hard for me
to put what I want to say onto paper
before I'm never going to school I still
can't read and write seven million
Australian adults struggle with literacy
nine million are challenged by everyday
numeracy
unable to read a timetable count change
or follow a recipe
I had people riding for me pretty much
most of my life I'm just managed with my
phone like how to go to work how to buy
shopping everyday life is a battle
people judge
think if you can't read and write you're
stupid I've told myself that I'm not
good enough
every day of my life if I want people to
think that you're a dummy because you
can't do them things
in this groundbreaking series we reopen
the classroom doors for nine new adult
Learners what would you call that price
if we're using rounding and this time
around lessons don't just cover literacy
but also numeracy all through school
maths I never understood it as 53 of
Australian adults lack the necessary
numeracy skills for everyday life you
know learnings about trial and error you
have to be brave enough to make a few
mistakes it will test their resolve at
every turn for me to be able to write
something in front of an adult that
scares the out of me you're right
yep and I'm embarrassed to put it on the
wall because it's messy
with nine weeks of demanding classes and
real world challenges no idea revisiting
the basics will be tough you reckon
we're here this is the massive part this
is the party this is the goal this is
the goalie that's exactly right will
confronting their fears push them over
the edge I've been trying to do it for
so long and it's so hard and I give up
or take them in new directions
my name is Lemmy this is my first time
reading out loud to everybody I believe
in myself and I love myself and I am
enough for myself I'm On Top I'm
and ultimately set them on a collision
course for success
yeah right now I have been publishing a
news article about Afghan woman wow so
impressive now I just want to go and
achieve everything it's never too late
if I can you guys can too with broke
down walls that people don't normally do
and it's more than just completing a
course
it's finding a bit of yourself
[Music]
thank you
something's going on
[Music]
I want people what is all this we're
going to Hawaii it's actually Bali
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is Eddie it's great to meet all
of you
guest feature and YouTube sensation
Eddie Wu helps the world find joy in
maths um I wonder if anyone has any
guesses as to why the room is dressed up
the way it is because we're gonna go to
Hawaii are you Hawaii not as exotic as
Hawaii is where we're going to think
about today but nonetheless if we were
to consider
going
on a little bit
that's our road trip now oh let me put
that on do you like that that's you know
clearly someone was thinking someone's
having a dig
I grind we're all coming up to your
place drinks are on me okay fantastic oh
we're gonna hold you to that you might
regret it no problem Graham travels from
Tamworth every week to attend the course
so this class is especially relevant to
him from Sydney to Brisbane where are we
going to plan out our stops do I want to
stop at Graham's place
[Laughter]
but it's also relevant for the rest of
the group because it's everyday mass
that we all use when traveling
you guys know it's like roughly 100k's
an hour on a highway
um and you've got to stop a little bit
right it's still got the toilet there as
well so I'll put it put it as well
right another toilet break okay and then
you've got Gosling to Newcastle which is
90 so that's uh it's 170 K's I don't
think a lot of people realize they were
doing maths today they'll just enjoy and
chit chatting planning a holiday it's
good at weddings okay Leanne come on up
uh Focus to your journey and
particularly why we are leaving at
5ammy's going to wake us up let me okay
5am so then we're going from Sydney to
Foster okay so this is our first stop so
we'll move up here what time is it now
roughly around about 10 a.m about 10
because it's sort of like brunch time
yeah
so it's 11 when we leave Foster and
we're going to Coffs Harbor okay for two
hours to take some pics it's going to
take Lemmy about two hours to get some
picks we left at 11. yeah hopefully what
time do you think about 2 p.m yeah 2 p.m
ish okay I'm gonna call this
um Lemmy's selfies yeah two hours
it was really good like like a bit of a
game it was actually a good way of doing
it to be quite honest and
um it made our little brains really work
over time so yeah that was good we're
we're saying that we'll get to Brisbane
in about
4 30 4 P.M finish
when I was at school teachers weren't
like the teachers like Eddie was today
let's give me another team of hands well
done hey
on enjoying this on me outside my box
I'm 500 K's away from my home and I'm
I'm embracing it
so
for me
numerous is just about solving problems
that matter to me when when numbers come
up and when it can help me to Think
Through logically where do I want to go
where's a place where's a way that I can
enjoy this and also take my friends
along for the ride